Her low freak bitches.
You know what is true,
right.
You could guess based on their,
their past and the precedents.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
It's very fluid.
Geez Tom.
She's doing all right.
I mean freaking us out by train.
That's so quick.
I drink a lot of water.
Sorry.
No,
no you don't.
That's the first time you've cracked it.
Open.
What?
Jesus.
Yeah.
You guys fighting?
I hydrate a lot more than he does.
Oh,
is this an issue?
But it's not close.
You hydrate more than of course not.
I've been hydrating this whole time.
Interesting.
But,
but he has that drink too.
That's
smaller.
Smaller being,
I weigh like a fraction of what he was very tiny and petite.
Oh Geez.
Look at my uh,
moniker on dad mouth.
But look at water.
The water champion.
Is that what you tell people?
Yeah,
I'm clearly the water champion.
We've decided this.
I got to do a,
I got to do a full new show a lot of times,
you know,
they go,
you're doing like eight minutes.
I did the entire Brock.
I did the weather and everything.
All his Dj,
dad mouth.
What city was this in?
Demoine really happy were there.
They were just,
Oh my God,
what are you doing in De Moines?
I was,
I was there.
I did two nights.
Just had the funny bone.
Is it fun?
Yeah,
I had a really good time.
A really good time.
Did you come up with this Dj dad mouth thing just like it?
Was it a specific like like a plan or did you do it for fun?
For Fun?
Totally for fun.
Just to shoot one day and then we just did.
What happened was tell Joe the whole story when I was eight months pregnant and
he's like,
I'm going to buy like a ton of deejaying equipment.
I'm like,
wait,
what are you doing?
He's like,
I'm by like $10,000 worth of Shit in her house.
And I was like,
all right,
this is your,
I clearly knew this was his last Hurrah as a free person.
So I try not to give him too much static and then sure enough all his DJ stuff
shows up,
not 10 grand.
And you've got decks and fucking lights and lasers and the real Russell Peters,
he's got a lot,
well he's a real Dj.
He does.
He goes to clubs.
Yeah,
he can do it.
He doesn't make it a face.
She was making a face because I was like I'll get good enough at this to do
after parties after my shows.
I was half serious cause I was like,
you know what,
cause I,
you know,
I've,
I love hip hop.
I've always grown up and I've always wanted to do it.
So I got the,
I got like,
you know,
introduced.
I'm not 10,000,
not even 5,000,
like not even close to that.
I just bought turntables and got um,
for jackets.
Gold chains.
No,
but come on,
that shit was just silly to get,
you know,
you were a DJ today and you were trying to spin turntables.
Don't you think people would be asking to take selfies in the middle of it and
it would fuck up your flow if I was deejaying.
And if you were like doing an after party and people have tried to take selfies
with you,
you just take a selfie.
It'd be I'd be up there,
but on my Facebook,
yeah,
you're probably right.
Yeah,
for sure.
They would.
Yeah.
I have to be honest,
who really gave me the idea idea where I was like,
oh,
like this is actually possible was Hannibal,
because I was in Cleveland earlier this year and I saw him tweet that he was in
Cleveland doing a pop up show.
Right.
He just tweeted out and doing like a whatever,
like a rock club pop up show,
no advanced notice.
So I texted him,
I was like,
I'm over at Hilarides that great club in Cleveland.
Uh,
when is your show?
And he said like nine and go minds at eight.
You want to do a guest spot?
And he goes,
yeah.
So then afterwards he had an after party at the,
uh,
and I,
and that's me basically geeking out on the decks.
Yeah.
So,
and then Tony Trim,
which is,
uh,
the Dj that travels with him was like,
oh,
did you can just get this and like you can just buy this stuff and,
and,
and that's what really got me to do it.
Throw one up.
Let's look at that white guy dance.
Move
that move.
You're doing there.
You're doing this.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's what really geeked me out.
Was that
the name?
Dj Dad math came because he was becoming a father at the time and I was like,
you're like wait lane Browley or me a dad.
And then it kind of morphed into Dj Dan.
That's true.
All that's true.
But taking it onto morning news was like a one time ago that was like so funny.
I was like all the time,
you know?
So when you went on as a onetime goof,
did you have a plan or did you just not really,
I was just like,
the fun thing was to go was because I,
the thing that I hate the most when you do,
they're like,
what can audiences expect this weekend?
They always say that,
oh,
I hate that.
And I'm like,
oh,
fucking show jokes.
Um,
what are you talk about?
Yeah.
What's,
what's bothering you right now,
Tom?
Yeah,
that's the setup.
Tell what's going on in your life and they think just your there and then they
go,
just do whatever you want.
Like,
just have fun with it.
So when they do that,
I was just like,
it's not really,
I don't really give a fuck about comedy.
And then they were like,
what?
I'm like,
it's about the after party,
you know,
I'm gonna be DJ here just to goof on them because it was fun to have around and
be like,
all right,
you are at the funny bone,
right?
I'm like,
I mean,
for a minute
Mike,
I don't really care about it.
Funny Bone.
And then you have the funny bone sitting right there off camera like
carrots.
Like the best part is when he sets up like the really cheesy anchors to ask him
stupid questions like,
did you,
oh,
you had someone do the bird is fat thing.
That was the best one.
Because you know,
if you ever add,
sometimes when you go,
hey,
um,
you know,
ask me about farts or something,
they'll be like,
eh.
So they,
they know not to,
they check themselves on asking something provocative or that's not a hundred
percent PG.
So I didn't know how it would go,
but I go,
oh,
ask me my bird.
So fat and the lady goes,
okay.
And then,
so we just are in the middle of this interview
and she goes,
White Bird,
so fat.
And I was asking a good question.
I'm like,
I just rolled with it,
you know,
and then it grew.
And then a hot dog eating champion,
a guy that was in thing,
Scott Shalon she placed to any place.
Yeah,
he's like one of the,
he was like a super competitive eater.
Like a Kobiashi dude.
Yes.
This guy.
Oh,
this guy who assigned you play the audio on this.
That's incredible.
Life changing stuff.
Um,
I've dropped about a hundred pounds in eight months off.
He dropped her hundred pounds.
My cheat day for the here,
but wow.
Prepping just this amazing water and I have two giant inspirations first,
my wife.
All right.
Second anniversary today.
I want to say hi to her and um,
there's a comedian I love,
he's a big giant fat guy just like me,
Bert Chrysler Tom.
He's still way bigger than I am.
Maybe I can inspire him.
There you go.
Now for people who are wise is funny.
This is why it's funny,
Tom and Burt had been doing this thing for a fucking year now where Tom will
write out the Hashtag burn is fat and then Bert were right.
Tom Is fat and then they'll argue,
they make videos with their shirts off,
arguing who's fatter.
Yeah.
It was fun.
It's actually,
you know,
it's died down a lot,
but like the fact that that guy did,
he did it on his own to put a picture of you up.
Yeah,
I see.
Hashtag burn as fast as I talk about you.
If I tweet about you hashtag burns fat.
Oh yeah.
I really took off mean that we didn't like we talked about on your mom's house,
but we never thought we do all kinds of silly stuff,
but this one really resonated with the audience.
Why did that one really resonates?
Um,
uh,
you know what?
There was,
there was great theories about this and I,
and I think it was this,
I think Matt full Trump pointed out to me the full charge said,
um,
you gave him the formula,
you gave audiences a joke formula.
Here's a person,
it's a fat joke.
Go,
go ahead.
And I think that was what,
what was fun for people was to say like something,
just to jump in on something that it's all like the formula is there and you can
just to pick a side.
Yes.
That's the competitive nature of it.
Yeah.
And they know that you guys really are good friends.
Some did,
some did not.
I would say most,
most people did.
Most people did.
Some people get mad.
Oh yeah.
So people were like really fucking really harsh and really like,
fuck,
I've always fucking hated Barry's a piece of shit.
Like you're like,
Whoa,
like shit like that.
But it wasn't the majority.
Some people were like that though.
Yeah.
Same thing to me.
Some people,
some people were like,
you know,
it's one of my theories about this Trump thing.
I think people just pick off.
Okay,
okay.